My next guest, retired U.S.
Admiral Mike Mullen, spent
four decades serving his country,
and then he served as President
Obama's chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff.
And he's joining me
now live from Annapolis, Maryland.
Admiral Mullen,
welcome back to the program.
So, you know,
the word Bermuda has been on
everybody's lips for a long, long time.
How do you assess it's its nature
to the prosecution of this war?
Well, I think it's I basically agree.
I don't
I don't think strategically
in terms
of the progress on the ground
that it's overly significant.
But I do think
from both sides, actually,
both Ukraine and Russia,
that it it provides it's almost symbolic.
And it's been six or seven months that
the Ukrainians have
been fiercely defending
back Mount
And it's also
been obviously
that long that the Russians
have been attacking it.
And one of the things that
it's just a fact is because of the effort
in defense, the Russians have expended
a tremendous amount of resources.
They've lost thousands
and thousands of soldiers,
that they've
lost an enormous amount of equipment.
And so whether tactically,
it's a huge gain or
loss on the ground,
I think in terms of impact of the war,
it's had a significant impact
on what Russia can do.
And I think it in its own way,
starts to limit what they can do
in other places.
For instance, in the South,
which is a place you just talked about
So, Admiral Mullen,
you just mentioned something
that the NATO has just
just confirmed, at least
an official of NATO's
actually talking anonymously
saying that they believe Russia has lost
perhaps five times as many forces
on the ground as Ukraine
during this battle for Obama.
So, you know,
you just explained
what that might mean for
Russia trying to, you know,
secure itself in the south.
But also, let's just stick
with Ukraine for a second.
Because you've all described it as
a pretty much kind of a do or die
and certainly symbolic.
You remember
President Zelensky went to Obama
on the eve of his visit to Congress.
He brought back a flag that he said
a soldier from
Bermuda gave him to take
to the United States.
So it's hugely symbolic
and they've lost a lot of people.
How will that affect
the mindset of commanders and troops
if they have to
then turn around
and launch a counteroffensive
somewhere else?
Well, I
think knowing
what they know
in terms of the progress of the battle
and it's
it's a city, I think it's some 70,000
and reports are now
there are four or 5000 left.
And also
viewing the the photographs of the rubble
that black mud has become,
which I think is
what Putin is trying to do
across the country
to ruin
as much of the country as possible.
You know, it will have its effect.
That said,
those losses that we described
earlier with the Russians
are typical of their inability to fight.
And I think one of the things
to your point
about the counteroffensive
when it comes in the spring,
we will find the Ukrainian military
much more capable
of what
we call combined arms
training, the coordination of air
artillery, armor.
They will have much more armor
available to them,
if you will, and the Bradleys
and the strikers that are over there.
And so I think in the
in the long run,
it puts Ukraine in a much better position
to fight, to continue the fight.
And. And I.
Russia's given me no indication
that they are capable
of dramatically changing how they fight
while they continue to sustain
sustain these huge losses.
And I think that will be
that will happen
in the counteroffensive as well.
So, you know, we again
heard from the head of the sorry,
the head of the Volga group,
who is Prigozhin
who is complaining bitterly,
along with his forces
of a lack of ammunition,
a lack of shells and the like.
But we also know that Ukraine is lacking,
that we know
that the EU is earmarked
$1,000,000,000 for one
55 millimeter artillery shells,
but they haven't got them yet.
And you're talking about this
spring offensive,
which to be fair,
in spring is March 20th.
That's just three weeks away.
Do you think they're ready for a four
an offensive to start that soon?
Well, I think
the question is a great question,
because in a way, Christiane, this fight
has evolved into a battle of attrition.
And so
and battles of attrition are oftentimes
won by that, the health
or lack thereof of the industrial base.
So clearly,
both sides are focused
on this potential shortage of ammunition.
And it's really critical,
particularly for the Ukrainians
to be very selective
about the use of the munitions
that they have,
because obviously the supply
isn't infinite.
But you also hear that,
you know,
Russia's having the same problem.
So I think everybody's aware of that
and the commitments as well as
creating the production lines,
which is which can be a problem as well,
which will produce that the munitions
for the future fight. And I think
everybody would like
one would like this to end
you know, immediately.
Secondly, there's discussions
on how it ends.
But my sense, Christiane,
is this counteroffensive
and the results of that for the rest of
this year will really set the stage
for when this ends.
And I actually hope
that it's sooner
rather than later,
sometime late this year,
Yeah.
And of course, sooner
would benefit the Ukrainians
because they are less numerous.
And the Russians,
Putin thinks he can outwait the West
and obviously unity.
And and all of this is being tested
right now.
I want to ask you a couple of things
just to follow up on what you just said.
If you were the commander,
what the battle
you know, the battle zone commander now,
what would you say Ukraine needs in order
to have a successful counter offensive?
What does it need to focus on
and what equipment, training?
You know, sophisticated armed systems
does it need now?
They've been
the Ukrainians have been exceptional
in training
throughout this fight
over the course of the last year.
And actually before that.
I would argue
that a great deal of the training
they did between Crimea in 2014
and 20, 22
has served them exceptionally well.
They continue to train
and this combined arms training
I think that they are going through
now will make a significant difference
in the future fight
and that's what I would emphasize.
And then back that up, obviously
with the weapons
and the systems that they need.
Many people are chasing the the F-16.
It's almost like it's a shiny object.
And I think eventually
we'll get two F-16s for the Ukrainians.
But in the meantime,
that's not really what they need.
They need
the kind of artillery,
more high margin,
more precision guided munitions
to be able to strike deep
at the Russians
and have the kind of impact
they've had in the past.
That to me.
Well, I think make a huge difference
in what happens over the course
of the next six or seven months.
Look, let me push back a little bit.
You say in many, many in the in the NATO,
you know, group
says that that's not what they need
when they talk about fighter jets.
But, you know,
the leopard tank was a shiny object
that was being held back for a long time.
And now they are getting them
at least
they're trying
to get them as fast as they can.
And you all are saying that
actually they need
that kind of
of of projection of power, etc.
So why do you think
they don't need aircraft?
And what we also have heard
is that some
Ukrainians are being trained outside,
including in the United States
on simulators to figure out,
you know, exactly how to furnish them
with these fighter jets,
whatever they might be.
Why do you think they don't need them?
I don't
think I
didn't mean to say
I don't think they don't need them.
I think they will eventually get them.
You mentioned
the training
that is being reported right now.
What they really need
and they have actually been
very good
at this is
they need the air defense systems
And if you go back
to very early in the war,
the number of Russian aircraft
that got shot down
in the first couple of months
was really extraordinary.
So the the ability to impact,
you know, the Russian aircraft as well.
And I recognize that
at some point in time,
we're going to have to go deeper
because there are Russian aircraft
launching weapons from inside Russia,
which is where we don't want to go.
And I just think,
Christiane, that that it's going to take
it's going to take a little more time
to develop that capability
to get them to a point where those
where the F-16s would be
handled in an optimum way,
I think they're coming
obviously not as fast as both
President Zelensky
and his military would like.